all right it is time for drew's news
your daily trip to the news forest to
forage for good news mushrooms
and with me at the desk best pilot in
the biz or co-pilot oh you're a pilot
we're we're each other's co-pilot i'm a
fun guy to keep the mushroom pun going
hi everybody hi guys
hi
i love this yellow
but guess what else is happening rossi
what there's bridgerton news oh my gosh
i know i wish we had our veils and our
accoutrements tiaras um our favorite
dreamy and steamy show
is back on netflix this friday
took you long enough
it has been a long time coming and
stylist reports that the director
julianne robinson says what makes their
sex scene so different is she shot them
from the female gaze
for example she took that age-old scene
that we've all been seeing a dude laying
in a bed admiring a gorgeous woman's
body and
flipped the script on it letting daphne
sit back and admire the duke in the buff
yeah it wasn't just daphne by the way
and i love it i love that they're
shooting this from like flipping the
scritch from the the female point of
view and like focusing on like let's
objectify the men a little bit and hello
you know who's watching bridgeton the
gays and the girls so thank you
right you know i don't think it's big in
the sports bar necessarily yeah no no
in the sports bar i'd like to see that
that's a flip of a script let me tell
you i'd be there uh
monday through friday and on the
weekends too thank you so much talk
about a happy hour
all right next up we've got a new trend
at business schools across the nation
this is fascinating students are
learning how to be happy yeah the wall
street journal reports the hottest class
at harvard business school heard of
harvard
is called leadership and happiness and
it's taught by arthur brooks and he uses
science academic studies buddhist
teachings and bible verses to help
students learn how to cultivate their
own happiness and he says happiness
comes from four key areas in your life
listen up he says friends
family
your work and your faith or your
philosophy
i think he's missing fun i would say you
need a little fun in there too can we
add a fifth one
gotta have fun
he says they're all important though and
ask students to assess which areas they
might be neglecting because that's where
they need to do their work and if you
think about it those are the areas in
your life where you know you can have
like three of those four going right but
that one little thing you know if work's
not going right it's hard to focus on
the rest you know
i love that this class
has been created and developed and
within seconds of uh
the doors opening and the seats being
able to be filled
attendance goes like that you can't get
in and i feel like this approach to the
spiritual the
mental wellness the happiness uh
our work-life balance
it's so funny that we go to these
institutions and we're not focusing as
much on the life as we are the learning
and
interesting i think what's great
is to
to see an appetite for it because maybe
the way these students are coming in
droves to this class
will
make a bit of change for them being more
available and the thing about college
unlike regular school which makes me
have an aha moment about why the debate
is so rich is because so much of college
is elective
um versus lower schools so i'm glad to
see this available well i am too i think
it says something that these happiness
classes filled up so fast i mean that's
there's a demand for it and as somebody
who was forced to take like calculus
okay
i could have used a happiness class at
some point it would have been nice but i
think that that maybe them showing that
the demand is there we'll make other
schools offer something like this as
well and i think the word happiness gets
a really bad rap as if it is some lofty
hippy dippy
silly notion right and it is a war you
will fight every day and you will win if
you find it and you cultivate it and you
harness it i think happy is very hard to
achieve absolutely but it is worth it if
you can find it it is and we have to
figure out
ways in which to do that and it's
different for everyone
and it's a multi-layered thing and i'm
glad to see that
our wellness and our
excitement for life can be fostered in a
college community i think this is so
good
life matters
absolutely i wish i could take that
course
maybe we can
[Music]